[Música]
y estaba buscando un nombre para la
empresa pero entonces me plantee la
pregunta de cómo guardaría yo en mi
teléfono a mi proveedor de chorizos
entonces descubrí que yo lo hubiera
guardado mi teléfono como el man de los
tories
[Música]
paramos
ah
[Música]
yo tomé el producto como una bandera
para poder vender mi propia cultura
entonces eso es como una excusa para
hablar de colombia para compartir pues
en este país lo que significa ser
colombiano
[Música]
yo nunca me imaginé estar en parís
recorriendo las calles puedes entregando
chorizos
[Música]
me alegro mucho hermano para empezar
me alegro mucho porque yo sé yo sé lo
que es empezar y por eso tenemos una
meta bastante apretadito asta
pero bueno me alegro mucho que ya tenga
el trabajo del corazón bien mi suegra
que está en colombia le hablo a mi
esposa de hecho y le contó acerca de
juan nos dijo hoy mira allá hay un señor
que le dicen el man de los chorizos y
verdad tal vez te pueda dar trabajo es
colombiano y así fue lo buscamos por las
redes sociales solamente para pedirle
trabajo pero no sabía que era una
persona tan importante influyente aquí y
pone al otro de una publicación de juan
no eso nos abrió mucho trabajo una
explosión en redes sociales
saludos en europa llevamos tres meses
arreglan uñas la idea es quedarse
trabajando acá o que será que te voten o
no justificó para instagram yo tengo la
como la costumbre de tomar la política
de los clientes by poner y aprovechamos
su apoyo
[Música]
si considero que es un compromiso muy
grande el tema de que la gente me busque
hoy en día como para trabajo y para
tener oportunidades en este país claro
es una responsabilidad que hoy en día
pues me pesa en la espalda y que muchas
veces me quita mucho tiempo con mi
familia de mi trabajo también porque
esto es una cosa pues que yo hago de
manera voluntaria
pero es una cosa que disfruto mucho
también
[Música]